here's Johnny scratch that it's Danny's
time to shine well we'll see about that
actually
dr. sleep is an adaptation of Stephen
King's novel of the same name but it's
also set in the same universe as Stanley
Kubrick's 1980 film The Shining here's
everything you need to know before you
go in this sequel we pick up the story
of Danny Torrance the son of Jack
Torrance played by Jack Nicholson in the
shining before we dig into the film
let's talk about the cinematic version
of The Shining for a bed Jack Nicholson
starred as the terrifying and now iconic
husband and father who takes his wife
Wendy and young son Danny to work as
caretakers of the Overlook Hotel for a
winter season after spending some time
there the family is tormented by visits
from ghosts in the hotel but Danny is
different and that he has a special gift
of psychic ability she called it shining
just like you probably thought he was
the only one his father on the other
hand is not so lucky and succumbs to the
pressures of the evil spirits that live
there in the end he goes crazy and tries
to kill his family he should have
listened to his wife
hey wise tip she's always right the 1980
film was based on the novel The Shining
written by best-selling author and king
of horror novels Stephen King
Mike's movie stands on its own but it's
also a terrific sequel to Stanley
Kubrick's film and in 2013 Stephen King
published his sequel novel - the 1977
original book King said he always
thought to himself what would have
happened to Danny considering the
amazing gifts he had I always wondered
what happened to Danny when he grew up
then I felt that I had a story to tell
it's important to understand the
approach taken any adaptation of dr.
sleep director Mike Flanagan more
strictly followed the dr. sleep book for
the plot and borrowed from Kubrick's The
Shining to use as a visual guide was a
movie I was desperate to see the story
of dr. sleep revolves around Danny
played by you and McGregor still being
haunted by the trauma he experienced as
a
child at the Overlook Hotel he even
meets a young child who has the same
gift as himself danny assumes the role
of her protector as she is vulnerable to
terrifying spirits but instead of using
his abilities he rejects them we also
see an old friend appear dick Halloran
but we have questions the cook dick man
hollering played by Scatman Crothers
died at the end of the shining film we
see him in the doctor sleep trailer so
is he a ghost that Danny is able to see
or did he survive you can also look
forward to seeing Rebecca Ferguson she
co-stars as the villain Rose the Hat the
leader of an evil cult called the true
not Karl umbly is dick Halloran and we
have newcomer Kiley Curran who plays
Abra Bruce Greenwood also appears as dr.
John fun fact
director Mike Flanagan and his crew
painstakingly recreated iconic moments
from The Shining no footage from the
original film was repurposed so now you
know and now you can go see dr. sleep in
theaters early on October 30th only
through Fandango